[Music]
thanks for everyone for being here and
for those of you watching on the
livestream thank you for joining this
session my name is Ray I'm a developer
advocate for Google cloud platform and
I'm had a a develop advocate jetbrains
and today we're going to talk a little
bit about writing mobile applications
and the especially the backend and you
know I know a lot of you are probably
you know writing mobile apps today and
you're probably aware with you know you
know how to use Kotlin and where you're
learning to use Kotlin and then what
about once you have the front-end what
about the backends writings today's what
we're gonna talk about we're gonna show
a little bit about the different
frameworks that you can use specifically
spring bootie and Couture and we're
gonna see how we can actually deploy
this onto Google cloud platform by using
App Engine a few other things so for
this we've we've got this amazing
awesome Android application that neither
rain or I wrote because we both
completely suck at Android development
it was written by Seth where's your
hands so if anything goes wrong is also
his fault
and basically what it is it's just a
uploader so you can upload your images
and then you can do list them and do
some sharing and black and fire black
and white filtering and that's what
we're going to show you how to develop
on the backend side of it right and
that's pretty much all we have for today
and for the slides and we're gonna try
to code everything in the next 40
minutes or so how many people would
think that we can actually do this well
nobody Oh a few people Wow thank you all
right let's get started so they're safe
yeah so we're gonna get started so the
first thing that I'm going to do is to
write it back in using spring boot okay
and we're going to implement puppy half
of these functionalities and the one of
the easiest way to get started that's
actually equal to start a spring dial
and this will help you boost wrap your
service or your application in the
backend and how many people here use
great oh great oh yeah just about every
one maven
this is phew that's nice right so I'm
actually use maven last I'm gonna use
the maven project but you can choose but
I think we can all agree on that we're
gonna use Kotlin for the language here
if you scroll down a little bit you can
choose some of the the metadata here
like the package name and stuff like
that but most importantly I need to make
sure that is the
Packaging format for our demo today
we're going to deploy a war file for the
web application but in the future you
can also deploy a jar file as well if I
scroll down even a little bit more this
is the important part where we can pick
and choose the capabilities I want to
add to my application so for example I
already added the web dependency because
I need to be able to respond to an HTTP
request I'm going to use some of the
Google cloud services and so I'm going
to add GCC support I'm going to cut down
on some of the boilerplate code that
otherwise you may have to write for your
back-end
so I added this rest repository which
I'm going to show in a minute okay and
from here you can generate a new project
will be a zip file you can just download
it and you can unpack it and you can
open this up in your IDE okay so this is
a fresh new project which I just created
and I'm gonna open this up and there we
go
and I'm going to just make sure that I
can synchronize this they're actually a
little bit so I can get the latest file
if I scroll down here I can actually
open up the Kotlin application and for
spring boot is a very popular framework
that people use for the backend today
and this is how it takes like all these
lines of code this o it takes for you to
start an web server that can handle some
requests so for example if I wanna
handle well request access hello the
first thing I do is to create a class
that would be something like hello world
controller like that ok and then you can
create a function here say hello phone
hello
and then maybe I taking a name via the
request parameter
that's the string and it's gonna be
equal to your hello with a name and I
can annotate this with hello rest
controller and then for the function I
need to listen on a get method so I can
use kidnapping and listen to the hello
URI and that is all I need to do to
create a end point that responds to the
slash hello now for this application
though we need to do a lot more than
just saying hello world
we need crud operations we need
something that's restful so typically
what people do then is to go ahead and
implement and using the controllers
using these mapping annotations you
implement the rest of the API so for
example you need post to create a new
object you need to use get to retrieve
the list of photos delete and put it to
for the update and deletion right
and there's a lot of traduce you may
have to use to add to your application
and these are some boilerplate code now
in spring what is really really cool is
that they have a project called sprint
data and this allows you to add object
mappings to your data class so in our
case we have a data class here called
photo that has other attributes I wanna
join the database and what I can do is
to go to my dependencies here and I can
actually just add a dependency here for
our data store so you can use object
mapping to sequel databases in the
backend or in a MongoDB or in my case
I'm going to use cloud datastore which
is just a note that has no sequel
datastore a document oriented datastore
that you can use Google cloud platform
and once you have added this dependency
in the data class all you need to do is
to say annotate it with entity
annotation so that week till spring that
this data class can be stored in the
backend database somewhere and for the
IDE I'm going to mark it as a primary
key by using the ID and annotation and
just like that okay so now spring
understands is Theta class the next
thing that we need to do is to implement
some of the crud operations rather than
implementing all of the operations
ourselves which is going to define an
interface I'm going to call it photo
repository like that it's going to go
hang it extend something called the
paging and shortin repository for the
type of photo that's the domain type and
the key type is string and just like
that the Spring Framework will
automatically implement the crud
operations for you so now I can actually
safety that I can retrieve data we're
not go even a step further we're going
to put this as a restful resource as
well and this will also expose the fraud
operation as restful resources I can hit
from my endpoint Ronnie and see cities
up and running so in my team guns you
say from an application and spring
police trot up in about five seconds or
so there we go and this is ready to
handle some requests it's listening on
port 8080 and from here on out I can't
just go ahead and say I can make some
requests right and the easy way for me
to do it and I can use curl I can use W
get but I'm just going to create a new
file I'm gonna call this request HTTP
and I can't just go ahead and you know
make a get request so I can go ahead and
say maybe say hello to myself
say hello name is equal to rate and
let's run it and there we go we can see
how low right right and we can go and
test out our repository in the backend
as well for this one I'm going to go
ahead and say port 8080 I'm gonna see if
I can find a list of photos now my
laptop's already authenticated with
Google Cloud and so when I'm doing this
operation he actually connected
connected to the data store and I can
clearly see I have no photo data entry
here
right so we can go ahead and just try to
post something so I'm going to say PTR
let's post a JSON entry here so I'm
going to say post to 80 82 photos I'm
gonna say the idea is I'm just not make
something up 1 2 3 and maybe your eye is
hello something whatever that we can add
and let's go ahead and post it and we
can see clearly that this post operation
also went through and not only that we
also cut out your i/o back and this is
the unique URL that spring already
implemented for us and we can for
example can go ahead and get it as well
and we can see the details all of these
things are already stored in the data
store database ok so for example I can
go ahead and go to my Google Cloud
console I can go to data store right
here and I can see all of the entities
that have already created in our case we
have photo and that is the entry I just
posted I can of course 3d date as well
so I can do that from here from the
console if I want to you yeah there he
goes okay but we need to do a little bit
more than just CRE D operations on a
restful resource we need to be able to
upload a file because remember we have
to upload a photo now where would you
actually store the photo you can
actually store that you know typically
what people do is maybe store them on a
disk and Google Cloud we have something
called Google Cloud storage and with
Google storage you can store your binary
blobs so whether it's audio video photos
or whatever and you don't have to store
that only with this you can just push it
to the surface and you don't have to
worry about the space that you're going
to be using because we will take care of
that for you and so in our browser here
I can see clearly I have a Google Cloud
Storage bucket this is a top-level
directory if I go into it I have a demo
directory and from here I this is where
I'm going to put the photo that we're
going to upload and because of this I'm
going to
go ahead and uh you know add Mike add a
little prefix here in my controller so
this is where I'm going to store my
photos and I'm going to just create a
upload handler here for uploading the
photo right so in this case I'm going to
handle a post method on slash upload and
I'm going to go ahead and try to restore
the file that we are going to get from
the perimeter and the what we're going
to do it is by because we have
integration with the spring ecosystem
what we can do is to just grab a what we
call application context and this is
something that spring will automatically
inject into your constructor if you
declare it and from this context we can
go ahead and create a resource we can
say app application context key resource
and use the prefix and the ID as the
file name and this reference now points
to the file that may or may not exist
okay and from here from the resource we
can just go ahead and write our data
into a sum from the output stream I'm
gonna use it and I'm going to do the
right here we go right and right from
the fight's from the file and that is
all I need to do to upload a file in my
Google Cloud storage environment okay
and finally we're going to add this
piece of metadata into our data store as
well so I'm going to just use the photo
repository that I created earlier and
again we can use dependency injection
just by adding the photo repository here
and we can save photo repository that
saved the photo item here and the ID is
equal to the ID we pass in and the URI
that you can use to retrieve the photo
I'm gonna say image touch ID and that is
how you can implement a post method I
can upload handle upload of a file we
need to also retrieve the file so for
this one I already wrote in it out so
basically I have your eye mapping here
for image and you can see the ID here is
in part of the path and we just use
annotation here to link and say that
this variable is actually coming from
the path and similarly we can do the
deletion as well and as you can see
rather than writing a lot of the
boilerplate code were just using these
integrations to do the deletions and I
can delete the data as well okay so with
that I'm gonna go ahead and deploy they
seem to a production environment now
usually usually you want to try this out
in your local
first but we don't have a lot of time so
go ahead and deploy this into Google App
Engine App Engine is a platform as a
service that you can use to run your
production app and we can actually run
your calling application and cutting
services as well the easiest way for you
to deploy this app is by using our IDE
plug-in code cloud code so from this IDE
you can go ahead and add the App Engine
support into your project okay so I'm
going to go ahead and select it and this
will just add the support for the IDE
and also add a file code the App Engine
web.xml I'm going to open this up a
little bit and show you what you can do
here so this is where you configure the
deployment runtime environment so we are
using the runtime here where by default
it's going to give you a pretty small
instance that you can run a small
application but for us we're going to
increase the instance class size so we
have a bigger instance size so we have
more memory that we can use and also by
default it's going to use automatic
scaling what that means is that if no
one's using your application it's going
to downscale your app instances to zero
so you don't have to pay for it if
somebody makes the request we're gonna
spin up the instance for you
automatically if your application is
very popular then we'll sping up even
more instances for you for my team I'm
just going to go ahead and use the
manual scaling here so that I always
know I have two instances running in a
given time right so this is pretty much
ready to deploy but I'm also gonna just
add a little filter here for my own for
my application so what I just add is
just a little filter here that's gonna
be looking for some secret headers that
we're going to pass alone so that our
application can communicate with us okay
so it's almost ready to boy and in the
IDE we can also go ahead and just get
the configuration here and we can
configure the Google App Engine
deployment and let me just gonna add one
oh I think there's one here already so
we can pick and choose the application
we want to deploy and then we can pick
and choose the Google cloud project that
we want to deploy to and we have a demo
project here that I'm going to select
and then if I go down even a little bit
more we should be able to see the the
promotion like
what version we wanna use but go ahead
they apply it and say okay and now I'm
ready to deploy okay someone go ahead
and run this appointment
remember what's gonna happen behind the
scenes it's gonna compile my color
application it's going to create this
war package it's gonna upload everything
into Google Cloud okay and it's also
going to give you a URL that you can
actually use okay and very quickly we
should be able to see this application
up and running now I'm gonna go back to
my console just to show you this service
that we have created so this is the
console where I have the new service I
created and I will have a version that I
just created as well and as you can see
here at the traffic is not actually
going through to this new version
because I was not able to check the
check box for promotion but now I know
that this is deploying and we're going
to migrate all the traffic to this new
version as well okay so now we're going
to shift all the traffic from something
that doesn't do that doesn't respond to
any requests and I'm gonna shift it to
this new application I just wrote that I
hope it's going to start and work and
let's take a quick look okay so I should
be able to go to this new application
and oh nice I think this is working so I
should be able to say hello to myself
there we go
so I just wrote this and this is
actually up and running if I go back to
the Android app now remember the intro
apposition retrofit to talk to the back
end right now and if everything is
working fine I should be able to go
ahead and find one of the photos and
maybe we can upload it and remember it
goes into the slash upload Handler and
and very quickly issue return and we
should be able to see this picture okay
I'll go complete and let me see here
just make sure this is still there yeah
there it is and we are able to upload
our photo pretty cool right so let's
yeah so for the next part hadees' gonna
show you a little bit about how to write
this in couture
yes and I'll probably try and talk a
little bit slower okay yeah okay so yeah
so Kate or is how many of you have heard
of Kate or oh wow cool so Kate or is a
connected system application for writing
it doesn't say there
I'll say micro-services cuz then
everybody likes it microservices using
blockchain no there's no blockchain but
it'll sound nice as well and AI there's
no AI either but it will be cool so this
is essentially Kato is a multi-platform
library framework that allows you to
write server-side and client-side
applications okay so what I'm gonna show
you today is how you can do server-side
application and it's built from the
ground up with Kotlin using co-routines
as well similar to start dot spring dot
IO we have start docket or die io which
has again similar functionality so you
can select whether it's a Gradle or
maven project the different features you
want etc but I'm gonna show you that you
can do this also in the IDE so I can say
new project here I'll select a tour I'll
say that I want some static content
that's going to ask me for some
information I can even add a swagger
model if I want there and go ahead and
finish that and now I'll select auto
import and ok and now I've got my
caterer application
imported into IntelliJ and essentially
you can see that it's created a single
file which is where my application
starts right so in this case and I'll
explain this in a second but basically
I'm responding to a hello world and I'm
responding to some static resources so
if we go ahead and run this this will
essentially start up catering on one
cool thing about cater you'll see is
that they actually start time is
significantly faster than some other
technology which I'm not gonna mention
that someone was showing so I already
have this case or application running
and you can see that I have hello world
there okay
now let's switch back to our actual
application and let me show you a little
bit how this works so first of all
you've got your application routing now
if you look at the demo what I'm doing
here is essentially I'm putting all of
my different routes inside of a table
which is called the routing table now
this is great for demos but it doesn't
actually scale that well if you're doing
a real world application right you can't
have everything in one file unless
you're doing JavaScript right so here
what I want to do is no disrespect to
JavaScript what I want to do here
is try and separate things out so for
instance I can do a home function and
then I can have a file called home here
where I actually write everything that
has to do with my home routing etc and
you don't need to use functions you can
actually use classes if you want as well
that's the flexibility of Couture so
whereas with spring you have to map
basically your controller to these
routes with Cato you can use functions
or you can just use classes however you
want so I'm gonna write a function now
this could be any function but since
we're Kotlin what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna create an extension function on
route and what that gives me access to
some of the features of actual Couture
so here I can now do get and then I'll
say that get the home path and I'll do
something like call respond text and
hello right so this is basically going
to respond with hello from my actual
route so you can see that if I run this
and notice that when I'm running it I'm
using this little line here which is
allowing me to run this locally using
jetty and remotely using a different
deployment engine so that's one of the
cool things with Cato as well that you
can actually run something locally with
one end with one engine and remotely
with another so you can deploy with
Nettie run locally with jetty and I can
pass different configuration files it's
using ho con format for configurations
so you can see that I have my
application config which is what I ship
when I want to deploy but for debug I
actually indicates that I want to set a
specific port etc so let's go ahead and
run this and you can see that I've got
my application now running locally
responding to the actual endpoint so you
can see that it's running here and it's
not running because I've got another
application running which I should be
stopping this okay so now it should be
able to run ok so now I launch this and
I've got my HelloWorld there ok now
let's go ahead and develop some of those
things that we were talking about so
first thing I want to do is implement
that button that converts to monochrome
so look how fast I type okay so there is
our monochrome thing now that I was way
faster
way faster way faster so here what I'm
doing the exactly the same thing as we
saw before but in this case it's a put
okay so I'm loading the image with call
parameters and then I'm doing call load
from storage now call is part of K tour
but load from storage is actually a
Google Cloud function okay but again
we're dealing with Kotlin so I can
implement an extension function that
actually talks to cloud storage and
integrate that as part of my application
call which is the response request that
Kate or deals with so I load this from
storage this is gonna give me back a
result
I'm a good boy here because I'm
basically analyzing a success and a
failure I'm going to then converts it to
monochrome which is a really really bad
implementation of converting the
monochrome and then I'm gonna save to
storage if everything is okay I'll hit
OK if if something goes wrong what do we
do we always throw internal server a 500
it doesn't matter what it is just a 500
is absolutely ok and then you can
actually point to the real message with
a text okay so on that as a joke by the
way I've been sarcastic so internal
server error and now I go ahead and run
this now this is nice
I could actually deploy this and it
probably will might work might yeah but
the problem is that here notice that
I've got this like mono slash ID and
then I've got this ID and this is
essentially text and if I want to rename
this if I want to rename this route this
is kind of like problematic right
because I got to look for search for
text I mean if you're using IntelliJ
I'll probably fix it for you but let's
try and do this in a better way and what
we can do is implement this location
functionality that comes with K tour
which basically I can say that search
for location and I'm going to create a
class called mono that has a single
parameter which is ID and then what I'm
gonna do is instead of using this format
of put I'm going to use put a generic
type of put which is mono okay so that's
going to import the correct mono which
is location and then instead of using
call parameters what I can do is
actually this is a lambda so I can pass
the strongly type
ramita to my function which is all of
the parameters that are part of the
route so here I actually need to define
the route properly so it would be ID so
here I would do ID and then instead of
doing this call parameters like that I
can just access it via ID now in this
case it would be sorry this would be
mono dot ID and this this would be mono
dot ID okay sorry mono and then Monod ID
now if you're familiar with calling you
know that if lambda takes a single
parameter I don't have to be explicit
with it so I could actually remove this
and just refer to this as it okay so
this gives me its dot ID and now I have
access to my tie to my route in a
strongly way in a strong way so I have
access to the parameters I don't need to
do any conversions or anything like that
and this will actually work if I deploy
this this will work but the problem here
is that this is kind of slow I know
because I implemented it and if this is
running very long Cato will try and
prevent your threat requests from
blocking however it is recommended that
you offload this to another co-routine
okay so essentially what I would do here
is go ahead and write with context and
then dispatchers dot IO it has nothing
to do with this conference because that
was that was not funny no no okay
so now what I'm doing is I'm putting
this into the dispatchers IO IO which is
really cool because now it's going off
into another thread it's not blocking
any potential requests coming in and I
don't have to worry about safely putting
things back because with co-routines I
can just dump on access wherever I want
where I want
okay and this will now convert an image
to monochrome now before we deploy let
me show you some other things that you
can do with Cato
so here is a t-shirt okay so what this
is not a t-shirt is share and what this
is doing is essentially allowing me to
share an image so when I click on the
share button it's going to give me a URL
that I can then paste and send to
someone and it will share it and what
I'm going to show you here is how Cato
can actually send back HTML
as well now of course I could do
something like HTML like this and string
but that isn't cool what we can do is
combine this with Kotlin XHTML so I
couldn't in fact write body and then
here write for example h1 and then write
the lambda and then say for example
hello look at this image and then let's
do a br and then let's do for example
the actual image that is showing the
image okay so I'm integrating very
nicely the called NH x HTML library with
Kate or works very nicely and you can
just basically send back HTML now before
we deploy this one thing that we've got
to be aware of is we need to add this to
our routing table so if I go back to
main I have to come here and write
convert to monochrome and I have to also
do the share so I've now added this to
my table and then I should be able to
just deploy to App Engine
here I'm going to say promote this to
the next version select really seriously
you have to login first everything is
awesome and everything is broken can we
sing that no we can't allow the two to
turn the thing yes go ahead button there
you go I can't complain that this isn't
my machine because it is my machine so
I've deployed this and now it is
successfully deployed it's uploaded it's
already started and you're still
deploying your spring right working but
has it started it's always starting it's
always yeah I have menu scaling okay
yeah manual scaling so this is done
sending a traffic split for service so
now I can basically access my endpoint
but instead of accessing keys accessing
it like that let me go to my Android
application the SEP wrote and remember
if anything goes wrong here it's his
fault so we've got our images here and I
can click on my image over here and I
can this is that this is the moment of
truth convert to monochrome come on come
on come on come on
so come on
so this first request might be a little
slow because you have automatic scaling
right so we're actually starting a brand
new instance for you behind the scenes I
also put error while hip stirring image
hipster what does that mean
I think hipsters make their images
monochrome oh I'm waiting for along so I
know K so we can actually switch over to
the thing happened yes switch over to
and we switch over to raise machine yep
okay so tell me what's going wrong man
well let's let's see boy so what is
pretty cool here is that you can see we
actually deployed two different services
so his application did not overwrite my
service right so we can specify the
different names for your applications so
they don't overwrite each other so
default is the one I deployed that's
using swing boot and the k201 is the one
that he deployed using Kato of course if
I go in here I can see the different
versions that we have and this is the
latest version that he deployed and
that's the previous version that should
ideally work that I did it work so we
can fix this for example by simply
shifting the traffic and migrated to the
version that works and I will take care
of it but I'm kind of interested to see
what is going on behind the scenes so
for that matter we can go to into the
diagnosis tools and I can go in and see
we can do a few things we can debug the
code live or you can see the logs I'm
not sure you log for now so let me see
if I can get any log messages Oh
check check it out so we actually do
have a put here with a 200 so it
actually kind of went to you and then we
have a mano right and we can see some
log messages here it looks like it might
be okay so let me see here then going to
go ahead and do a refresh and Oh
actually know what it didn't actually go
there you go you see it more steps false
yeah something on the front end yeah but
we
so we actually planned that so that we
show you that error logs really right
yeah yeah okay yes yes so there you go
so we're gonna switch back over to my
machine please yeah but that's me Hadi
yes there you go so my they don't know
who my is so the last thing that we're
going to do is opening up this
application again where's my application
we also have the share so basically this
copies it over to my browser and I can
come here and I can paste that into my
browser and you say hello look at this
image okay so you got to share with the
HTML as well it's okay you can clap it's
okay I know so we've got that now it's
over to you yeah so wait a second though
let's let's switch back to my machine
again I'm gonna show this application
very quickly now Hadi check this out
when I open up this picture which I took
check it out there's a little label and
underneath here that says wood because
that's the material I guess I was used
to make this thing if I click into the
this other picture
it's got insects right and tell me don't
tell me that you're gonna add artificial
intelligence to this talk it's already
there
oh my god this is so cool it's already
there right so I can't actually eat this
one you don't have a talk without AI
right you have to have ml nai that's
right so I'm gonna upload one of my
favorite picture is really cute dog it's
not my dog by the way I wish it is but
if I go in there it's actually a part so
what did that actually come from you
show me write the code I can guarantee
you that everything I just wrote was
live the application did not write it
label into this artifact so what
happened behind the scenes is I actually
deployed this other thing way before the
talk is called a function in Google
Cloud would have cloud function so you
can actually write a very small snippet
of code and you can respond to events
the event can be coming from HTTP or it
can be coming from like things like
Google Cloud storage so that when you
upload a picture or any of the files we
can trigger this function as well if you
are using firestore or some other things
that we have you can also receive
notifications when you make changes okay
so go ahead and go back to my IDE and I
actually opened up the function right
here so this is a function that's
written with Kotlin right and function
you can run this code it's fine and one
thing you have to watch out for is that
you do need to actually create the class
and then you wrap the actual function
inside of the class that's because we
actually need to instantiate the class
for you so that we can you know
initialize some of the client libraries
that you may actually have to use and
this function is going to take in an
event right so for example if an HTTP
we're going to have some kind of HTTP
request and response in our case we're
going to respond to a Google Cloud
storage event which was a well defined
schema that you can read the
documentation for but you actually
definitely have these two fields in
there it's really a JSON format and
we're going to serialize it for you into
your data class as well so in this
function we have a pipe vision label
that's going to receive the event that
has the bucket and also the file name
that's been changed and we basically
just use cloud vision API to to read
this file and see what's actually inside
and so here we are actually doing a
feature a label detection we're going to
only get the maximum through results and
then for the labels we're going to just
iterate through the actual result list
we're going to sort by descending by the
score and then we're going to map it to
the description and finally you're going
to add it as a delimited delimited list
just a string that's delimited by a
comma and this is all happening behind
the scenes and synchronously at the way
that you would deploy this function is
pretty straightforward
actually if I go to here actually you
know what I'm gonna open the readme here
so it's a little bit easy to read so if
I want to put the function I can just
say G g-cloud function tree calls are
COI because they G call function deploy
and then give it the name of the project
and also the entry point which is the
class name and also the method name and
then you can specify the event trigger
that you want to listen to so for our
case we're listening to the Google Cloud
storage object event trigger okay and
that is how we then run the vision API
and then we update the label and of
course if I go to my console here let me
go back to my IDE okay
or actually you know what I'm gonna call
here and if I go back to my application
my App Engine application if I cope
to the service that I have just deployed
in default there you go let me open this
up and let me just open up the photos in
point because I remember this is where a
spring implemented all the crowd access
for me and I can see very clearly even
though I just wrote the URI my function
actually wrote the label for me that is
one ugly JSON what do you mean it's ugly
it's called like underlined inside
ii-i've got much better jason really
open up my app and yeah we've got two
different apps right we've got the spare
and we've got the cater
go to my app okay yeah it's got more
okay slash data okay slash all okay now
that's some nice-looking JSON is it
happy I think you have a way of crashing
the system with Jason's gonna bring up
the Jason thing now I've a in that work
today in the morning either thank you
so what what's going on there I'll open
up the panel another four hundred arrow
here let's take a quick look so we kind
of really show you can go in and see the
log let me show you something else here
so we can alter the request that's
coming through App Engine it's
automatically going through the trace so
we can actually go here and see the list
of requests so every dot here is a
request that's going through and we can
filter it by the request that based on
the HTTP status for example so we can
see uh-huh look there's your request
okay fine actually failed right and if I
scroll down a little bit we can also see
the log as well
so if there's correlation when we open
up this view log we should be able to
see the log message that's associated
with this particular request and look he
actually found this entry which is
pretty cool and we can see the five
hundred arrow right if I scroll down
even a little bit more you have an
exception here oh okay so I know what
that means so let's switch over to my
screen and I'll tell you what the
problem they're gonna fix out yeah I'm
alright alright right right okay so this
is the actual endpoint that he called
and what we see here there's another
feature of caetera that we're using
which is nested routing right so here
before where we were seeing just like a
get and the path you can actually have
even nested routes in cater so I define
a root and then slash all and in this
case all I'm doing is querying the data
store and then saying correspond now
this is automatically serializing this
to JSON the problem is as the log shows
is that I forgot to tell Kate or that I
want the JSON content negotiation
feature and the way that you do that is
that you come to your application and
you say install content negotiation and
then the content negotiation has support
for different types of serializers so I
could say for instance jisan and then
jisan has its own set of products
parameters right so I could say pretty
printer set pretty said pretty printing
right and because this is jisan it knows
exactly what ji-sun has so we have
support for JSON and Jackson etc and
that's what the problem was I was not
sending Kate or how to do the actual
serialization and now basically if we
deploy this again and I'm going to stop
that because we need to promote it so
we're going to deploy and it's killing
me so you can promote that directly but
anyway that should be promoted now and I
didn't promote it at the latest version
he's gonna now do it from the console so
while he's doing that I can switch over
and in principle this is still giving
the 500 era until he promotes the new
version from the console and then I'll
have the new version showing here and we
should be good promoted now yet I think
your deployment operation is still not
quite Phineas it's still deploying are
you connected to the Internet
okay yeah you are yes okay so yeah so
basically because he was doing the
deployment we cannot do you a
simultaneous operation here from the
console so now it should be migrating so
I just my machine I'm trying to migrate
the traffic over the puppy sold out
earlier are you getting into migrating
traffic week also split traffic between
two different versions of the app and
now let's microwave it over okay so you
see that I didn't hit promote and we did
it from the console yeah
so now switching over here we should be
able to see my JSON come back and it
doesn't matter even if it doesn't
because we're running out of time so
even if it gives a 500 error everything
is okay and all my Jason failed today
that's a record that's to Jason all
right great job
so that's basically it
switch back to the slides switch back to
my screen please so that we can close up
so we saw a lot I mean we went
relatively quick but we do have quite a
few resource you should probably go
visit so for example and obviously the
column pages but also you can go through
cloud.google.com slash Kotlin this is
where you can learn a lot more about how
you can actually write your coloring
application and deploy into Google on
patreon and we have some community
tutorials and collapse you can follow if
you want to do even deeper integration
with spring for example we have a whole
range of resources there and finally if
you want to try a google cloud function
you can stand up for that and you do
have to stand up because using alpha
right now and for Google App Engine we
do have a new version that's coming out
where you can also get the Alpha stand
up today so that you can try and deploy
a jar file instead of a war file okay so
that is all we have today and yeah
thanks I coming here thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]